let's start first jacob with what what
do you watch on the internet uh i watch
preston players preston plays mr beast
and unspeakable gaming all right it's
all like minecraft games why is
minecraft so popular uh i don't know
it's kind of a fun thing do lots of
things uh lots of different versions i
guess and
yeah it's just kind of fun gaming do you
build in minecraft or you just play you
can build you can play survival mode
it's really fun are you good at the game
um are you are you better than your
brothers
yeah easily yeah of course all right
yeah are you better than all your
friends at school no no oh no they're
better than you probably i like pvp them
but like
pvp them all right
all right person person all right
personally
i'm old now okay
pvp sounds a lot we used to say like one
on one yeah all right one on one that's
one on one but you call it pvp all right
what's up versus person all right you
got a cell phone no no no cell phone
number i have a little watch but you
have a what do you text on the watch
yeah yeah
wait you need wi-fi to be able to detect
something
oh
and then you're just off to the races
so it's kind of like a phone but you
can't you're kind of like in the secret
service like you and all your friends
are just like texting on your watches do
you know that when we had walkie-talkies
that didn't work no we we were cool we
weren't nerds
me and jacob we never had one jacob
wasn't here when i told the people that
i skipped school to read a book
that's a nerd right yeah exactly we
should get do that face again that was a
perfect face
that's nerd stuff right
get into topics and then we'll get
jacob's perspective on stagflation
i don't think i even know it's
stagflation
the world bank on tuesday slashed its
global growth forecast and were that
many countries could fall into recession
as the economy slips into a period of
stagflation reminiscent of the 1970s
what the hell is this is perfect we
literally have an olympia so i explained
like to an 11 year old uh do you know do
you know what inflation is uh yeah it's
i think where you have certain amount of
money and the government prints more
money so you have less oh my god
[Applause]
that was very good
that is exactly what happens the
purchasing power goes down so right now
there's high inflation right it's over
eight percent which is a forty year high
very very high and uh stag flation means
that at the same time that there's high
inflation the economy is slowing down as
well so usually what happens is when
there's high inflation right
everything's going stock market's going
up everyone's getting rich it's amazing
right but when inflation goes down then
the economy can contract but the bad
situations you get high inflation and a
slowing economy makes sense right so
isn't that kind of how the great
depression started
i feel like you can't
have him
uh not exactly but uh it can lead to
very very bad times yeah and uh the
further that you get into a recession do
you know what a recession is no
idea all right so a recession is
basically every uh quarter right every
three months uh there's a number that
comes out it's like a magical number
they basically go and they do all this
math and they say the economy grew or
the economy shrank and what that really
means is how much uh economic activity
happened okay and so last quarter in
january february and march they said
that it shrank
and so a recession is if we get two
quarters so three months and three
months of shrinking then we're in a
recession right so we already got one
how many more do we need before it's a
recession
uh another quarter
very good you must be a a genius in math
class
so
jacob this is live so there's a bunch of
people in the chat right now and
somebody said jacob has trillionaire
entertainment
he said yeah i do all right so so the
problem right now is everyone's very
worried about if inflation is high which
it is uh both in the united states and
elsewhere uh if we go into a recession
then it's something called stag
inflation right the economy is stagnant
right so that's the stag part and
inflation inflation some genius
somewhere try to put the two words
together and make up a new word called
stagflation that'd be the problem so it
could happen we don't know yet uh but
that is a big risk because that's
basically like uh you ever played a game
and it's like double trouble right like
one thing's bad nothing's bad you put
them together it's double trouble
stagflation is double trouble
essentially
so apple what's going on all right
so apple do you have an apple watch no
it's not an apple watch oh okay now what
you got you got a calculator watch
they don't need those anymore they don't
make those no i think i wish because
then i'd be like math
[Laughter]
so apple was trying to turn into a
fintech company and it announced several
new features for the iphones
oh wait
wallet app why did i read this as a
watch app the iphone's wallet app the
big one is a buy now pay later service
and that's competing with a firm which
is a company that does that
when you go to buy something if you
don't have money what happens uh you
can't buy it you can't buy it right
wrong guess what they got new they got
new companies now that what they do is
they say you want to buy something you
want to buy this iphone but you don't
have money for it well we'll give it to
you now and we'll put you on a payment
plan oh yeah you heard about these
you are in debt they don't call it debt
because debt sounds bad so instead they
call it buy now pay later yeah it's kind
of like when you buy a house and you get
a mortgage famous for it exactly it's
very similar yeah okay but here but
here's the whole thing by the way you're
a genius somebody knows more than i do
you should run jp morgan uh
if um
by the way people in the audience are
saying tell anthony we have to replace
joe with this kid
who's one of my brothers uh so when you
think of buy now pay later the idea is
that they give it to you now and then
you're on a payment plan and basically
what they try to do is underwrite the
risk are you gonna pay me later or are
you not right and the reason why they're
willing to do this is if this is a
hundred dollars you may have to pay a
hundred and five dollars over time but
they make their five dollars you get it
now and then you just pay on the payment
plan and so there's a bunch of companies
that started to do this all across the
world and they're very very valuable but
then apple showed up and was like you
know what i think we're just going to
get in that game and so it's kind of
like you know if you're at the
playground and you're playing the game
and the bully shows up game's over right
the bully just showed up apple just
showed up and now the game might be over
we're going to see what happens to the
other companies but they're not so
excited that apple showed up makes sense
yeah all right debt that that that's
what we're going to do we're going to
rebrand all the buy now pay later
companies it's just debt
all right what's up with paypal so
paypal is going to let users transfer
certain cryptocurrencies to other
customers exchanges and external wallets
it it's a new service that's part of the
company's effort to boost usage of the
app so
do you remember when i interviewed the
paypal ceo and he said that he thought
of course
if i would have liked him go ahead but
anyway i asked him if he he personally
owned crypto and you said i do and i
said like what do you own and he said
bitcoin and i asked him only bitcoin and
he said only bitcoin
and paypal has since kind of improved
further yeah do you uh and your friends
talk about bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
well not really but sometimes me and my
brother talk to it yeah what do you guys
talk about uh
we i don't know just kind of how the
price is going how much money we're
incoming how much money is
yeah does he smell bad no no
that was a softball i was gonna let you
just talk bad about him you didn't do it
that was pretty good all right so uh
most of the of your friends they're into
uh bitcoin and cryptocurrencies or no uh
no not really oh i mean yeah no i can't
find them yet well they allegedly can't
buy it yet uh they're playing minecraft
they're busy on the internet yeah um so
i look obviously every single company
that must be uh competitive in this
space it's gonna allow people to buy it
move it off of their platform move it
into their platform it kind of would be
like you ever have a a bank account
where they say hey you could put your
money in but you can't take it out yeah
i wouldn't use it right
so now they've got
but paypal got a bit license in new york
yeah of course so what does that mean
well now they can service new york
customers but i thought new york was
kind of
well they all make you get a bit
licensed
if you're still trying to build a crypto
company in new york you just a little
living under a rock
until they lift the legislation huh like
patrick patrick that guy from spongebob
he lives under a rock yeah you're
surprised that i knew that aren't you
yeah you're like yeah yeah you're like
this old-ass dude knew what patrick from
spongebob spongebob is pretty old well
spongebob is old but also patrick lives
under a rock everyone knows that except
for you you were busy reading books in
the hallway all right what's going on
with cinnamon
so
you like this as a show baby just like
talk [ __ ] right it's kind of fun all
right all right so
u.s electronic trading giant citadel is
building a cryptocurrency trading
ecosystem with the help of this is a
world salad basically they're building a
crypto trading platform with this
company they don't know what they're
building yet they're true financial ones
yeah we uh so citadel and
virtu came together and they also have
sequoia in paradigm and they say they're
building a crypto trading marketplace
which is like what is a marketplace uh
basically they're not building an
exchange but they want to compete with
exchanges i think there's a new way that
they could build the ability to buy and
sell uh that would compete with the
exchanges but not actually be in
exchange right
do you know uh citadel have you ever
heard of them before no i have no idea i
have no idea i hadn't either did you uh
did you pay attention to gamestop did
you
when the stocks were all traded like
crazy that was sort of like my older
brother carter he's like i don't even
know where he lives
it's kind of all over anyways uh but
he's still in college and
uh
wait so you
he was trading gamestop yeah yeah he
kind of did that too yeah he was into it
yeah it's crazy because our nana used to
buy us like wheeze like all the time and
he's like wait what did you just say all
right so there's a game console called
called wheeze oh okay they
all right and uh he sometimes like trade
that out for games oh go on his other
ones got it so you could like barter and
get other ones all right so gamestop uh
one of the firms that was involved in
all of that citadel which was uh uh
buying a bunch of stuff from robin hood
robin hoods where a bunch of these
people were trading like so they were
involved in all that uh but they're run
by a really smart guy he's got ken
griffin very intelligent right very rich
uh he he bought a apartment you know how
much his apartment was i don't know
probably like a thousand dollars
yeah way more how much
a million i don't know
too low guess
a hundred again
more a billion no not a billion but it
was like 150 million dollars one
apartment that's good
apartment yeah exactly how big was that
i gotta get that he owns the whole world
now ken griffin owns the world
he has bought the whole earth like he
just owns it all
115. so that was just one apartment and
it was like a vacation one wasn't even
the one he lives in oh [ __ ] kind of
crazy right all right so they uh they're
gonna try to get into crypto now he made
all of his money in uh stocks and other
assets now he's going to get into crypto
kind of crazy maybe he'll make money
actually he's going to buy all of it
yeah maybe it's by the whole world i
don't think it's 150 million i think
it's 238 million oh i was uh i was i was
giving him too much credit he actually
spent 238 million wow
in new york city do you know how much
238 million dollars is that that's like
no that's like that's
if i said to you count to a million
right now and you did it today three
yeah all the way to a million yeah and
then you have to do it 238 more times to
get to 250 like the rest of my life
i feel like wait what was that oh nice
yeah mr beast by the way you said you
watch him that's remember when he
counted yeah he counted to 100 000 yeah
you're surprised i knew that right
all right what's the last time
okay so oh four day week perfect me and
jacob we're gonna sign us up for this
so there's this massive experiment this
is the largest experiment that's
took taken please took place whatever
taken place so far more than 3 300
british workers are trying out a
four-day work week which is part of a
global movement to test the strategy
seen as potentially improving business
and health outcomes instead of a full
week you go to work four days i'm gonna
ask you some very simple questions
uh when you want to accomplish something
what do your parents tell you that you
should do
try hard try hard work work hard right
stick with it if i told you that you
have to get something done and i say
that you have four days or five days to
get it done which one do you think is
better no it depends what i'm doing no
don't don't don't come in here with that
nonsense
how many days would you rather have four
days to work on it or five probably five
five and if you got done in four days
then you'd have extra day to do other
things right so what they're trying to
do is they want to go from having five
day work weeks to four day work week
yeah and they don't want to change the
output so you're working essentially the
same amount
but you but you get a day off you see
how confused you are i'm confused too
[Laughter]
my question is how are they going to
measure that these people are they're
not it's all [ __ ] it's literally all
[ __ ] sorry the closure
it's
all nonsense right is you can't say
we're gonna work on hard things and only
work four days instead of five guess
what happens do you know you know about
tesla yeah you know spacex you heard of
those companies right how many days a
week do you think they work
probably like all the days all the days
exactly all the days all seven like all
the days they work right why because
it's hard they're trying to do something
hard right and so it's like if i said to
you if you want to be good at minecraft
how many days a week do you have to play
to be good
all the days yeah all the days right
like every single day you have to
practice same thing here and so what
ends up happening is that there's people
who uh they're saying hey the business
isn't the most important thing which
okay fine that's that's fine you could
say hey i don't actually be good at
minecraft or i don't actually want to
solve the problem i want to enjoy my
life that's fine but there are certain
companies where it's going to be very
important that everyone goes to work and
works hard it's you know you know what
the biggest fear in society is
our biggest problem in society
is if we teach young people like jacob
not to work hard
that's what they're doing they're
teaching people not to work hard well
but here's here's my problem i hope
every one of our competitors only works
four days a week
what's your problem my problem is that
when you have a five-day work week you
know how on fridays people don't really
work that hard they're like oh it's
friday i'm going to go get a mouse after
or whatever so when you make it four
days instead of that happening on friday
it's going to happen on thursday so then
essentially you get like so you're
arguing four days is really three and a
half yeah
what did you see the math that goes on
in the show
but yeah it's true i i actually agree
with you that yes people will slack off
just a day earlier uh but if you're
sitting there if you and i were
competing with each other if i have a
business and you have a business right
do you hope that i work more than you or
less than you uh
probably less less right because then if
you're working harder than i am then
you're probably gonna win
right you're assuming that working hard
means working more days
you could get a lot accomplished in
three days i hope every single one of my
competitors works one day
and i will destroy them
12 hours days and you're working five
hours they can work whatever hour days
they want i hope they work one day a
week that'd be amazing it would make my
life so much easier so like in strategy
games like when we're playing on like a
playground stuff we play like infection
tag right and that was the
it's where if you tag someone then the
other person's it and it's kind of like
you think of strategies of what you're
gonna do and if you slack off and just
like run around for one day like i guess
like you have like one strategy that you
keep doing it's not gonna be very smart
because the other person can figure it
out and if you're like me then you're
gonna have lots of different strategies
oh you have a lot of strengths different
situations yeah wait tell tell us about
the different strategies okay so one i
just call it ring around the road
because i just get a beam or something
and i just run around it the whole time
oh okay
if the other person goes one way then i
go the other way yeah
that's a very complicated but very
simple strategy right then it can't
catch you yeah that's smart what's
another all right another strategy is so
i just kind of it's
there's like i guess it's kind of like
similar but uh
if one person's like running up the play
structure then i'll just jump off the
play structure and
that's like
yeah you call that like disappear like
they come up and then you're just gone
and then there's a couple where i just
like jump off the play structure and i
like hide behind the wall and have no
idea where i go and then walk the other
way yeah and then i just hop out and
then i'm like oh you got a whole
playbook like you're like drawing in the
sand you're like alright there you go
here i go here yeah nobody who ever has
watched this show thought that we were
going to cover the strategic elements of
playground tag but i just want you to
know one thing you may be smart you may
be 11 so you're like a little bit
smaller and you got high places and
everything i would destroy you in tags
no way no you you would definitely lose
go ahead you ever seen uh have you seen
on espn they have competitive tag oh
yeah well
they won't let me participate because i
would win please
[Laughter]
do you have any uh anything that you
want everyone to know you you can plug
anything in the world right now
what's the most important thing in your
life uh i don't know
what do you want everyone to know you
all these people are watching
do you have social media no i'm not my
parents no
do you have do you have anything that
you if you could say one thing to all
these people what would it be
have a great day oh that's a great
answer
have a great day and are you enjoying
miami yeah yeah do you want to tell
everyone what you do with the lizards
what
all right so i try to run and catch the
lizards in miami because they're so much
faster than me i hate it and i'm like i
can't catch you i will
did you catch any no no not yet yeah
have you huh have you i've caught a lot
of lizards in my life but let me teach
you a secret this this is a uh a classic
old man advice ready
you're never going to be faster than the
lizard so you got to outsmart it and the
way that you outsmart it is you and your
brothers
you find one and then you basically get
set up so that you got you are circling
it and then one of you chase it and
it'll run and run right to the other one
oh well what happens because sideways
like they're right here and yeah
right here you better hope your brothers
are agile you better hope your brothers
are agile if you're unathletic brothers
then you're screwed so you know you got
to tell them to make sure that they're
very predictable they go this way though
i mean there's an iguana almost i feel
like have you ever caught one an iguana
no i don't i don't mess with you
i i look at them like oh look at this
little fella right here
um i feel like in 10 years jacob will
probably be running a billion dollar
company and or running for president oh
wait no you can at 21.
okay 20 years
there's sometimes my wife says things on
this show and i just like it's the math
it's the public math but yes he can be
running a billion dollar company
we're gonna call you into the show in
the future so we need you guys to be
studying stuff all right
all right it was today fun yeah i'll
write down my watch phone number
all right that's it for today i
appreciate both of you joining us i
don't know where this kid came from but
uh he's here so you guys got to enjoy